This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. 6, 5, 4... Cast your mind back to the late 1990s. We have ignition and we have lift off of NASA's Mars climate orbiter as we continue to explore the mysteries of the red planet. It's the late 20th century, and as a threat of Y2K and rap metal crossover, loom large in people people's minds and NASA satellite blasts off towards Mars That's producer Joel Werner from the sum of all parts podcast
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。6、5、4……把思绪拉回到20世纪90年代末。点火成功，NASA的火星气候探测器顺利升空，我们将继续探索这颗红色星球的奥秘。那是20世纪末，千年虫危机和金属说唱的跨界风潮在人们心中挥之不去，而NASA的卫星正向火星疾驰而去。这是来自《万物之和》播客的制作人乔尔·沃纳。
22nds after liftoff Everything continues to go well So this satellite weighing 338 kilograms That's 745 pounds. Yeah, yeah, yeah, we'll get to that. So the satellite weighing 338 kilograms hurdles through space towards the distant planet. It takes nearly a year to get there and when it gets close, the satellite fires its main engine to go into orbit around Mars. Up until that point, all data from the spacecraft appeared normal. Everything was running smoothly.
升空22秒后，一切进展顺利。这颗重338公斤的卫星——也就是745磅。好吧，好吧，我们稍后再谈这个。这颗重338公斤的卫星在太空中向遥远的行星疾驰。它需要近一年的时间才能到达，当接近目的地时，卫星会启动主引擎进入火星轨道。在那之前，来自航天器的所有数据看起来都很正常。一切运行平稳。
The engine burn begins just as the spacecraft disappears behind Mars. Mission control waits for it to reappear, and they wait, and wait, and wait. But the spacecraft never emerges. The Mars climate orbiter is lost. I'm sorry to report that we have a serious problem with the Mars Climate Orbiter. We may in fact be facing a loss of mission. We believe the spacecraft came in at a lower altitude than we had intended, and that depending on how low that was and it's something we're still going to confirm, it potentially resulted in the loss of the measure.
引擎点火开始，航天器刚好消失在火星背面。任务控制中心等待着它重新出现，他们等啊，等啊，等啊。但航天器再也没有出现。火星气候探测器失联了。我很遗憾地报告，我们的火星气候探测器出了严重问题。我们实际上可能面临任务失败。我们认为航天器进入轨道的高度比我们预期的要低，具体低了多少我们还在确认，但这可能导致了任务的失败。
Scientists at NASA began to pour over the data, looking for clues as to what might have gone wrong. And before long, they figured out. The spacecraft was supposed to approach the planet at an altitude of 150 kilometers or 93 miles, when in fact its approach had been lower, much lower. The post-mortem at NASA found that a pretty simple arrow was to blame. A conversion error. The NASA investigative board confirmed the cause
NASA的科学家们开始仔细研究数据，寻找可能出错的线索。没过多久，他们就找到了原因。航天器本应在150公里（即93英里）的高度接近火星，但实际上它的接近高度要低得多，低得多。NASA的事故调查发现，罪魁祸首是一个非常简单的错误。一个单位换算错误。NASA调查委员会证实了这起价值1.25亿美元航天器失事的原因。
of the failure of the $125 million spacecraft. The NASA team at Jet Propulsion Laboratory assumed they were using the metric system to measure rocket firings while NASA was using the metric system, the International Standard for its calculations. But one of their contractors was using US customary units, the proper term for the American system of inches, pounds, and gallons. Years of planning, hundreds of millions of dollars literally up in smoke burned up in the Martian atmosphere and all because someone did the right calculation in the wrong
NASA喷气推进实验室的团队假设他们在测量火箭点火时使用的是公制单位，而NASA在计算时确实使用的是国际标准的公制单位。但他们的承包商之一使用的是美国习惯单位，即英制单位中英寸、磅和加仑的正式名称。多年的规划，数亿美元的投入，就这样化为乌有，在火星大气层中烧毁，仅仅是因为有人在错误的单位下进行了正确的计算。
units. This wasn't the only time a conversion error resulted in disaster or near disaster. In the early 80s an airliner ran out of fuel mid-flight after a metric conversion error and had to make an emergency landing. And in 2001, the LA Zoo loaned a 75-year-old Galapagos tortoise to an animal management program at a local college. The zoo warned that the Clarence, the tortoise, was big and needed an enclosure for an animal weighing 250 kilograms. But the college thought they meant 250 pounds, which is only 113 kilograms, about half his actual weight.
这并不是唯一一次因换算错误导致灾难或险些酿成灾难的事件。80年代初，一架客机在飞行途中因公制换算错误耗尽燃油，不得不紧急迫降。2001年，洛杉矶动物园将一只75岁的加拉帕戈斯象龟借给当地一所大学的动物管理项目。动物园警告说，这只叫克拉伦斯的象龟体型很大，需要一个能容纳250公斤重动物的围栏。但大学方面以为他们指的是250磅，也就是只有113公斤，大约是他实际体重的一半。
His first night in his new home, Clarence destroyed it. But these kinds of failures haven't been enough to get the U.S. to switch over to the measurement system used by the vast majority of the world. We Americans measure things our own way, in units that are basically inscrutable to non-Americans, nearly all of whom have been brought up in an all-metric environment. They use meters, liters, and kilograms, not yards, gallons, and pounds. You might have noticed that I'm a non-American myself. And while I've never lost a spacecraft to a distant planet, I have run into other problems,
在他新家的第一晚，克拉伦斯就把围栏毁了。但这类失败案例还不足以促使美国改用世界上绝大多数国家使用的计量系统。我们美国人有自己的测量方式，使用的单位对非美国人来说基本是不可理解的，而他们几乎都是在全公制环境中长大的。他们使用米、升和公斤，而不是码、加仑和磅。你可能已经注意到我自己也不是美国人。虽然我从未弄丢过飞往遥远行星的航天器，但我确实遇到过其他问题，
like ordering way too much delimit. Too much delimit is never a problem, Joel. I lived in the US for a couple of years, and while culturally a lot came easy, I never really adjusted to your measurement system. Australia, where I'm from, has been a metric country for over 40 years. I grew up metric. I don't really have a sense of how much half a pound weighs or how warm 60 degrees Fahrenheit is.
比如订购了太多的熟食。太多的熟食从来都不是问题，乔尔。我在美国住了几年，虽然文化上很多东西很容易适应，但我从未真正习惯你们的测量系统。我来自澳大利亚，那里已经使用公制40多年了。我是伴随着公制长大的。我真的无法感知半磅有多重，或者华氏60度有多暖和。
And two years wasn't enough to change that. So when I lived in the States, I'd routinely head out and cold weather without a jacket or come home with too much bacon. So why, with so many industries and people like Joel crossing borders with so much fluidity, has the US not fully committed to the system the rest of the world uses? As you might guess, it's complicated. So the magic system has a kind of complicated history in the United States. This is Steven Mim, a history professor at the University of Georgia, and the author of
两年时间不足以改变这一点。所以当我在美国生活时，我经常在寒冷天气里不穿外套就出门，或者回家时买回了太多的培根。那么，既然有这么多行业和像乔尔这样的人在频繁跨国流动，为什么美国还没有完全致力于使用世界其他国家通用的系统呢？你可能猜到了，这很复杂。公制在美国有着一段复杂的历史。这是史蒂文·米姆，佐治亚大学的历史学教授，也是一本即将出版的关于美国标准化历史书籍的作者。
a forthcoming book on the history of standardization in the United States. It's in the 1790s when the United States was first fumbling around toward fulfilling the constitutional mandate to create a uniform system of weights and measures. The metric system was at that point just a glimmer in the eye of a bunch of French revolutionaries. And there was some discussion at the time, led by Thomas Jefferson, that the US adopt a decimal-based system, kind of like the eventual metric system, but the idea didn't gain much traction. So when it came time to systematize American weights and measures,
那是18世纪90年代，美国最初在履行宪法授权以建立统一的度量衡系统时显得手忙脚乱。当时，公制系统只是法国革命者脑海中的一个微弱念头。当时在托马斯·杰斐逊的领导下，曾有过一些讨论，建议美国采用一种基于十进制的系统，类似于后来的公制系统，但这个想法并没有获得太多的支持。所以当需要将美国的度量衡系统化时，
we ultimately threw our lot with what we were working with at the time, which was the bushels and pounds and feet and so forth. America had inherited this old system of measurement from the British. It had its roots in Roman and Anglo-Saxon units, and then evolved over a thousand of years before American independence. But around the same time French revolutionaries were heading in a new direction. They opted to throw out their old system, which they found displeasingly irrational, and switch it for a new system. The metric system. The metric system is a decimal system, meaning it relies on multiples of 10. 10 millimeters become one centimeter,
我们最终还是选择了当时正在使用的那一套，也就是蒲式耳、磅、英尺等等。美国从英国继承了这套古老的测量系统。它植根于罗马和盎格鲁-撒克逊单位，并在美国独立前演变了上千年。但大约在同一时间，法国革命者正朝着一个新的方向前进。他们选择抛弃他们认为令人不悦且不合理的旧系统，转而采用一种新系统。公制系统。公制系统是一个十进制系统，意味着它依赖于10的倍数。10毫米等于1厘米，
100 centimeters become one meter, and so on. The French began promoting the system internationally, arguing that it would encourage trade and bring the world together, and it took off. By the mid-19th century, there was a growing adoption of the metric system worldwide. And as the metric system spread, some people in the US started to feel left out, like educators and scientists, they wanted the US to get with the program and officially go metric. It lends itself really well to scientific research and inquiry. And for educators, it's really easy to teach students and it makes a lot of sense. But abandoning the US customary system did not sit well with a lot of people.
100厘米等于1米，以此类推。法国人开始在国际上推广这一系统，认为它将促进贸易并使世界更加紧密，随后它流行了起来。到了19世纪中叶，公制系统在世界范围内得到了越来越多的采用。随着公制的普及，美国的一些人开始感到被冷落了，比如教育工作者和科学家，他们希望美国能跟上潮流，正式转向公制。它非常适合科学研究和探索。对于教育工作者来说，它很容易教给学生，而且非常有意义。但放弃美国习惯单位系统让很多人感到不适。
There was tremendous resistance. And the resistance came from a few different quarters, some of which overlap. But the most interesting was a group of astronomers, theologians, and cranks, and keep in mind that those categories, which we consider separate and distinct today, were not at this time. And so those people came to believe that there was a biblical basis for the inch, and that
存在巨大的阻力。这种阻力来自几个不同的方面，其中一些有所重叠。但最有趣的是一群天文学家、神学家和怪人，请记住，这些在今天被我们视为独立且不同的类别，在当时并非如此。因此，这些人开始相信英寸有着圣经依据，并且
that biblical basis was marked in the great pyramid of Giza and the architecture of that pyramid. This theory got more and more elaborate and gained a lot of followers, as the astronomers and theologians combine scientific arguments with other wild and nonsensical ideas. But welded it all together into what was for many people a compelling argument that to abandon the inch and then all of the other weights and measures was to go against God's will. So science and education with this newer, shinier measurement system versus religious sell-its,
那种圣经依据被标记在吉萨大金字塔及其建筑结构中。这个理论变得越来越复杂，并获得了许多追随者，因为天文学家和神学家将科学论点与其他疯狂且荒谬的想法结合在了一起。但他们将这一切融合在一起，对许多人来说，这成了一个令人信服的论点：放弃英寸以及所有其他度量衡就是违背上帝的旨意。所以，科学和教育支持这种更新、更闪亮的测量系统，而宗教狂热分子则
clinging to what they know fearful of change. It's a good story, but it's only part of the story. In the US, in the 1870s, the real core resistance came from a different group entirely, some of the most innovative industrialists of their day. The answer lies with engineers and with machine tool industry in the late 19th and 20th centuries, who had tooled up enormous vast factories and a vast industrial base, that by the 1870s sat at the heart of what was now the largest economy in the world.
固守他们所知的东西，害怕改变。这是一个好故事，但这只是故事的一部分。在美国，19世纪70年代，真正的核心阻力来自一个完全不同的群体，即当时一些最具创新精神的实业家。答案在于19世纪和20世纪的工程师和机床行业，他们装备了庞大的工厂和广阔的工业基础，到19世纪70年代，这些工厂已成为当时世界最大经济体的核心。
This vast industrial system included everything from lathes to devices for cutting screw threats, and it was all based on the inch. The manufacturers did not want to retool. They said it would be way too expensive, and not just that. They also argued that there was an intuitiveness to the customary system. You have an inch, you have a half inch, a quarter inch, eighth inch, 16 and so on. That kind of division on the shop floor, maybe not for a scientist, but on the shop floor, makes a huge amount of sense. And it's very simple, it's very straightforward, it's very easy to learn, and it's very
这个庞大的工业系统包括从车床到切割螺纹的设备，一切都基于英寸。制造商们不想重新装备。他们说这太昂贵了，不仅如此。他们还认为习惯系统有一种直观性。你有英寸、半英寸、四分之一英寸、八分之一英寸、十六分之一英寸等等。这种在车间里的划分方式，对科学家来说可能不行，但在车间里，却非常有意义。而且它非常简单，非常直接，非常容易学习，而且非常
easy to build machines around that concept. And all because everything is simply doubled or halved. And the arguments of these late 19th century industrialists proved incredibly influential. So to put this in a context, this would be like today, the tech sector and the titans of the tech sector pushing back and saying, you know, a metric system over our dead bodies. And so the industrialists and the cranks win this round. Subsequent generations make attempts to introduce the metric system to the US and they are met with subsequent generations of resistance.
容易围绕这个概念制造机器。这一切仅仅是因为所有东西都可以简单地加倍或减半。这些19世纪末实业家的论点被证明具有极大的影响力。为了说明这一点，这就像今天科技行业的巨头们站出来说，公制系统除非从我们的尸体上踏过去。于是，实业家和怪人们赢得了这一轮。后来的几代人试图将公制引入美国，但他们遇到了后代人的持续抵制。
Congress repeatedly brings up legislation to make the metric system not just legal, but mandatory. And each time the legislation goes down in flames. But then, in the 1970s, about 100 years after the first big push for metrication and on the back of a wave of metrication around the world, another attempt is made to bring the metric system to the US. And this time, it really catches on. Congress actually passes an act in 1975 declaring the metric system the preferred system of weights and measures for the United States trade and commerce. And then President Gerald
国会一再提出立法，使公制不仅合法，而且强制执行。但每次立法都以失败告终。但到了1970年代，在第一次大规模公制化运动约100年后，在世界范围内公制化浪潮的推动下，美国又进行了一次尝试。这一次，它真的流行起来了。国会实际上在1975年通过了一项法案，宣布公制是美国贸易和商业的首选度量衡系统。随后杰拉尔德·福特总统
Ford follows it up with an executive order. In both cases, the adoption of the metric system is deemed voluntary. But the government really tries to make it happen. Take 10 America to learn the metric way, to simple system based on 10s that you can start today, you fish in more accurate, more universal too, it's good for our economy, our cashier and for you. The US Office of Education ran PSAs like this one. People started pinning take me to your leader buttons to their jackets, that's LITER. There was a popular poster
紧随其后签署了一项行政命令。在这两种情况下，公制系统的采用都被认为是自愿的。但政府确实试图让它实现。花10分钟学习公制，这是一个基于10的简单系统，你今天就可以开始，它更精确，也更通用，这对我们的经济、我们的文化和你都有好处。美国教育部播放了像这样的公益广告。人们开始在夹克上别上“带我去见你的领导”的徽章，那是“升”。有一张流行的海报
soul that featured a woman in a bikini with a slogan think metric above her and her measurements in centimeters below. 92 61 92 turns out you can be sexist in metric 2. 2, 61, 92. Turns out you can be sexist in metric 2. Take 10 minutes to learn the metric way. Right metric education PO box 111 Washington DC, 2.0044. Take 10, this message is brought to you. With the 1975 metric conversion act, it didn't really have any teeth. It included the word voluntary, which meant that businesses
上面画着一个穿比基尼的女人，上方写着“考虑公制”，下方是她以厘米为单位的尺寸。92、61、92，原来公制也可以是性别歧视的。92、61、92。原来公制也可以是性别歧视的。花10分钟学习公制。写信给公制教育，邮政信箱111，华盛顿特区，20044。花10分钟，此信息由……提供。1975年的《公制转换法案》并没有什么强制力。它包含了“自愿”这个词，这意味着企业
and organizations could opt out of using it, so some organizations and industries went metric and others did not. That decision to take a voluntary approach to medication was different than the way a lot of other countries approached it, where they passed actual laws and made it mandatory. Taking a softer approach meant that the US adoption remained incomplete and vulnerable to opposition. Once again, the anti-metric forces began together. And once again, this resistance came from multiple directions. For one, there were the unions who
和组织可以选择不使用它，所以一些组织和行业采用了公制，而另一些则没有。这种采取自愿方式进行公制化的决定，与许多其他国家采取的方式不同，那些国家通过了实际法律并使其成为强制性的。采取这种温和的方法意味着美国的采用仍然是不完整的，且容易受到反对。再一次，反公制力量开始集结。再一次，这种阻力来自多个方向。首先，有工会，他们
were scared that moving to an international system of measurement would make it easier for big corporations to ship jobs offshore. Various writers and thinkers fought against the metric system too. People like author Tom Wolf and futurist Stuart Brand, the creator of the whole Earth catalog. Brand argued that the US system was, quote, more suited to humans. He pointed out that a human foot was about the length of a foot, and that a yard was about the length of a person's outstretched arm to the center of their body. It was more intuitive, he said. And then finally, there was also a political argument against the US going metric. As the
担心转向国际测量系统会使大公司更容易将工作岗位转移到海外。各种作家和思想家也反对公制系统。像作家汤姆·沃尔夫和未来学家斯图尔特·布兰德（《全球概览》的创作者）这样的人。布兰德认为，美国系统“更适合人类”。他指出，人的脚大约是一英尺长，而码大约是一个人伸出的手臂到身体中心的长度。他说，这更直观。最后，还有一个反对美国采用公制的政治论点。随着
Jimmy Carter era of the mid-1970s gave way to the Reagan era of the early 1980s, a variety of movements rose up against globalism and elitism. This is the issue of this election. Whether we believe in our capacity for self-government or whether we abandon the American revolution and confess that a little intellectual elite, in a far distant capital can plan our lives for us better than we can plan them ourselves, but beyond that. The U.S. economy was hurting and the nation's pride had taken a few hits.
1970年代中期的吉米·卡特时代让位于1980年代初的里根时代，各种反对全球主义和精英主义的运动兴起。这是这次选举的问题。我们是相信我们自我管理的能力，还是放弃美国革命，承认在遥远首都的一小撮知识精英能比我们自己更好地规划我们的生活？但除此之外，美国经济正在受损，国家的自豪感也受到了一些打击。
And as a result, anti-metric opposition began to take on a kind of defiant nationalism. And the metric campaign withered, I think, in the face of this, because it seemed to be yet another example for conservatives of the United States sort of selling out its patrimony to largely Europeans that seems to have been the kind of xenophobic subtext. You can imagine this You know, we lost in Vietnam and now we're going to adopt the magic system You know, what does the world come to? That's what this was sort of perceived as it was the pendulum swinging too far to this kind of namby-pamby internationalism.
结果，反公制反对派开始带有一种挑衅性的民族主义色彩。我认为，公制运动在面对这种情况时萎缩了，因为它在保守派看来，似乎是美国将其遗产出卖给欧洲人的又一个例子，这似乎是一种仇外心理的潜台词。你可以想象一下，你知道，我们在越南输了，现在我们要采用公制，你知道，世界会变成什么样？这就是当时人们对它的某种看法，它被视为钟摆摆得太远，走向了那种软弱的国际主义。
That sounds weirdly familiar. And all of this meant that efforts to metricate the US were left stranded, halfway between the old and the new. And in a typically American way, it was left up to the market to decide who went metric and who didn't. Which has led to this weird situation where get this, the US is already about halfway there. The US really is a metric nation. We just don't know that we're a metric nation. Sally Mitchell is a high school chemistry and physics teacher in upstate New York and a passionate advocate for the metric system.
这听起来很耳熟。所有这些意味着美国公制化的努力被搁浅了，处于新旧之间。以一种典型的美国方式，它被留给市场来决定谁采用公制，谁不采用。这导致了这种奇怪的情况，听好了，美国实际上已经走了一半了。美国确实是一个公制国家。我们只是不知道我们是一个公制国家。萨莉·米切尔是纽约州北部的一名高中化学和物理老师，也是公制系统的热情倡导者。
I mean, she's even written a metric cookbook. We use the metric system almost everywhere. Likker stores, medicines, everything is in grams, leaders. I have a water bottle here right now, it's 500 milliliters. It's there. It's just our choice. I can look at this bottle and see 16.9 flu announces. I can choose to read 1.05 pints, or I can choose to read 500 milliliters.
我的意思是，她甚至写了一本公制食谱。我们在几乎所有地方都使用公制系统。酒类商店、药品，一切都是以克、升为单位。我现在这里就有一瓶水，是500毫升的。它就在那里。这只是我们的选择。我可以看着这瓶水，看到16.9液盎司。我可以选择读作1.05品脱，或者我可以选择读作500毫升。
The US is on what's called a metric continuum. The fields of science and medicine are almost fully-metricated and with little controversy. But in the business realm, it's a mix. Some businesses are fully-metricricated, others not at all, and a lot are left somewhere in between. Here in the United States, we have large international businesses. Elizabeth Gentry is the metric coordinator in the Office of Wates and Measures at NIST,
美国处于所谓的“公制连续体”上。科学和医学领域几乎完全公制化了，且几乎没有争议。但在商业领域，情况则参差不齐。一些企业完全公制化了，另一些则完全没有，还有许多处于两者之间。在美国，我们有大型国际企业。伊丽莎白·金特里是NIST度量衡办公室的公制协调员，
the National Institute of Standards and Technology. NIST is the organization that standardizes measurement in the US. These are companies that have international supply chains. What they're looking for is the ability to sell the product in many marketplaces and they get the components for the product all around the world and they need to fit together and have a really reliable product. These are companies like Xerox and Caterpillar and Levi Strauss and they went metric during the Mettrication push back in the 1970s. And then you have on the other end of the spectrum small businesses here in the United States.
即国家标准与技术研究院。NIST是美国标准化测量的机构。这些公司拥有国际供应链。他们寻求的是在多个市场销售产品的能力，他们从世界各地获取产品的组件，这些组件需要相互配合，并拥有非常可靠的产品。这些公司包括施乐、卡特彼勒和李维斯，它们在1970年代的公制化运动中转向了公制。而在光谱的另一端，是美国的小企业。
And for these smaller local businesses, the economic imperative to metricate just isn't there. Like think of a dairy farmer. And there's just one thing that really holds us back. It's milk. And milk comes in a gallon. And milk is not shipped internationally. So the farmer can't afford to retool everything
对于这些较小的本地企业来说，公制化的经济必要性并不存在。比如想想奶农。有一件事确实阻碍了我们。那就是牛奶。牛奶是用加仑装的。而且牛奶不会进行国际运输。所以农民负担不起重新装备一切
to put it into leaders. And so it's been a gallon. Yet another unit that confused our intrepid Australian reporter Joel when he shopped in American grocery stores By combed Joel's milk comes in leaders not gallons have gallons and courts, and it's it's funny because most people don't know a Court and a leader which one's bigger Yeah, I don't know that like yeah, I have no idea Well, this is how you remember it. A leader is a leader bit more. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha on the other. But you've also got a lot of business caught somewhere in between, which is where it gets really tricky. Some companies end up having to maintain two separate production
来换成升。所以它一直用加仑。这又是另一个让我们的无畏澳大利亚记者乔尔在逛美国杂货店时感到困惑的单位。乔尔的牛奶是用升装的，而不是加仑、半加仑和夸脱，这很有趣，因为大多数人不知道夸脱和升哪个更大。是的，我不知道，我真的不知道。好吧，这就是你记住它的方法。一升比一夸脱多一点。哈哈哈哈……但你也有很多企业夹在中间，这才是真正棘手的地方。一些公司最终不得不维持两条独立的生产
lines, even two separate warehouses, to manage all the different versions of their products. It's a total headache, and it's expensive too. And so that's where we're at. We've got a nation stretched out across a continuum of medication, dual units, and conversion confusion. A history of near misses, bad timing, and it's all mixed in with a serious cultural resistance to the system of measurement adopted around the world. This cultural resistance highlights the difficulties of
线，甚至两个独立的仓库，来管理他们产品的不同版本。这完全是个头痛的问题，而且也很昂贵。这就是我们现在的处境。我们有一个国家处于公制化的连续体上，双重单位，以及换算混乱。一段充满险些酿成大祸、时机不当的历史，所有这些都与对世界通用的测量系统的严重文化抵制混合在一起。这种文化抵制突显了在任何地方
introducing a new system of measurement anywhere. Even the average French citizen hated their new system of measurement anywhere, even the average French citizen hated their new system when it was first introduced back in the Revolutionary Age. The bottom line is this, it's really difficult to get people to change from a measurement system they've been using their whole life. A nurse's resistance to change is a massive obstacle to overcome. You know, when I think about, all right, what's harder, occupying a country, conquering
引入新测量系统的困难。即使是普通的法国公民在革命时代首次引入新测量系统时也讨厌它。底线是，让人们改变他们一生都在使用的测量系统是非常困难的。这种对改变的抵制是一个巨大的障碍。你知道，当我思考，好吧，什么更难，占领一个国家，征服
it and putting it under your heel or getting them to adopt your unit of weights and measures. Like, you can do the first one, but the second one can really, really rough you up because it, it's even if people do it on the face of it, they're constantly converting back into the, to the ghost units that ghost units that have been banned. They just continue to do it. But resistance to the metric system in the US continues to have a subtext that goes beyond just preferring a familiar system. Today may be more than ever, the resistance to metric is about the rise of a new kind of
它并把它踩在脚下，还是让他们采用你的度量衡单位？就像，你可以做到前者，但后者真的会让你非常非常难受，因为即使人们表面上做了，他们也在不断地换算回那些被禁止的“幽灵单位”。他们只是继续这样做。但美国对公制系统的抵制继续带有一种超越仅仅偏好熟悉系统的潜台词。今天可能比以往任何时候都更甚，对公制的抵制是关于我们国家一种新型
nationalism in our country. Take the case of Sally Mitchell, who you heard from earlier. She's the high school science teacher from Upstate New York. Back in 2014, she stepped right into the middle of the whole metric versus US units debate. And it got brutal. It actually started out in Syracuse when the airport had gotten a new sign. Syracuse airport is an international airport, and the old sign had displayed the temperature in both Fahrenheit and Celsius, the metric systems preferred unit.
民族主义的兴起。以你之前听到的萨莉·米切尔为例。她是纽约州北部的高中科学老师。2014年，她直接卷入了关于公制与美国单位的争论。而且变得非常残酷。它实际上始于雪城，当时机场换了一个新标志。雪城机场是一个国际机场，旧标志以华氏度和摄氏度（公制系统首选单位）显示温度。
But the Celsius option hadn't been activated on this new sign. It was only showing Fahrenheit. So I called and they said, oh, we forgot to program it. Let me do it. It'll be ready by tomorrow. And I think I posted something online that said, don't you worry, it'll be fixed by tomorrow. And then the next thing you know at the newspaper was calling me and they wanted to do a story on this.
但这个新标志上的摄氏度选项没有被激活。它只显示华氏度。所以我打电话过去，他们说，哦，我们忘了编程了。让我来做。明天就能准备好。我想我在网上发了条消息说，别担心，明天就会修好的。然后接下来你知道的就是报社给我打电话，他们想就这件事做一个报道。
I said, no, no, not a story. Please don't know a story on this. But they did a story anyway. And then a radio station called and did an interview with her. And the host of that radio show would decidedly anti-metric. And they said, do you want a teacher that wants to drill her metric agenda into people's heads and how dare she and things like that? And they were mean and they were awful. The next thing you know it, phone calls to the school, I had threats on Facebook, threats through emails. I had people writing to me, demanding that I be fired
我说，不，不，不要报道。请不要报道这件事。但他们还是做了报道。然后一家广播电台打电话给她做了采访。那个广播节目的主持人坚决反对公制。他们说，你想要一个想把公制议程强加给人们的老师吗？她怎么敢这样，诸如此类的话？他们很刻薄，很糟糕。接下来你知道的就是，打给学校的电话，我在Facebook上收到了威胁，通过电子邮件收到了威胁。有人写信给我，要求解雇我，
because I just wanted the sign to display Celsius again. It got really crazy. The threats were so bad. And I had to report that to the police. And I thought, wow, people need to get alive for something or really think, why, why are you doing this? I'm doing this for science, I'm doing this for international communication, I'm doing this as an educator. Sometimes when Sally Mitchell talks about the metric system, you get the sense she's talking about
因为我只是想让标志再次显示摄氏度。这真的变得很疯狂。威胁太严重了。我不得不向警察报告。我想，哇，人们需要为某件事活下去，或者真的想一想，为什么，你为什么要这样做？我这样做是为了科学，我这样做是为了国际交流，我这样做是作为一名教育工作者。有时当萨莉·米切尔谈论公制系统时，你会觉得她在谈论
a lot more than the metric system. People like me are starting to speak up, and we're not going to have it anymore. This is not the way we are. We're an intelligent nation, and we want what's best for our children. We want what's best for our communities around us. And so that's why I'm speaking up now. I am more vocal than I've ever, ever been, and I'm just not going to take it anymore. I'm not going to let the ignorant be the loudest. Mm. But those anti-metric trolls that Sally had to deal with, she's pretty much guaranteed to have the last laugh.
不仅仅是公制系统。像我这样的人开始站出来说话了，我们不会再忍受了。这不是我们的样子。我们是一个聪明的国家，我们想要对我们的孩子最好的。我们想要对我们周围的社区最好的。这就是为什么我现在要站出来说话。我比以往任何时候都更直言不讳，我只是不会再忍受了。我不会让无知的人成为声音最大的人。嗯。但是萨莉不得不应对的那些反公制喷子，她几乎肯定会笑到最后。
Because those customer US units, the inches and pounds, they're actually defined relative to the metric system. Here's Elizabeth Gentry of NIST again. Usually consumers are at the grocery store, they may buy a gallon of milk, or they're at the gas station, and they buy a gallon of gas. They think, well, I'm using all of these US customer units all the time in my life. That must mean the United States hasn't really adopted the metric system. But the system that makes sure a gallon of gas in Oakland is the same as a gallon of gas in Omaha, that system relies on metric standards.
因为那些美国习惯单位，英寸和磅，实际上是相对于公制系统定义的。这是NIST的伊丽莎白·金特里。通常消费者在杂货店，他们可能会买一加仑牛奶，或者在加油站，他们买一加仑汽油。他们想，好吧，我一生中一直在使用所有这些美国习惯单位。这一定意味着美国还没有真正采用公制系统。但是确保奥克兰的一加仑汽油与奥马哈的一加仑汽油相同的那套系统，依赖于公制标准。
A gallon is officially defined as 3.78541 liters. So just below the surface, it's all metric. It's metric all the way down. You might think the debate about the metric system is over in the US, but a candidate in the most recent Democratic primary actually ran on a pro-metric platform. Spoiler alert, he did not get very far.
一加仑正式定义为3.78541升。所以就在表面之下，一切都是公制的。它从头到尾都是公制的。你可能认为关于公制系统的辩论在美国已经结束了，但最近一次民主党初选中的一位候选人实际上是以支持公制的纲领参选的。剧透预警，他没走多远。
More about that after this. In June 2015, Lincoln Chafey, the former governor of Rhode Island, announced that he was seeking the Democratic nomination for president. He said he would be running on a platform of bold ideas, like this one. Earlier, I said, let's be bold. Here's a bold embrace of internationalism. Let's join the rest of the world and go metric.
广告后继续。2015年6月，前罗德岛州州长林肯·查菲宣布他正在寻求民主党总统提名。他说他将以大胆想法的纲领参选，比如这个。早些时候，我说过，让我们大胆一点。这是一个对国际主义的大胆拥抱。让我们加入世界其他国家，采用公制。
I happen to live in Canada, and they completed the process. Believe me, it's easy. It doesn't take long before 34 degrees is hot. Only Myanmar. J.F.E ended up dropping out just four months later. He didn't do well in the debates and he wasn't raising much money and his poll numbers were low. It's like he just did not quite have his finger on the pulse of the nation. Here's Stephen Mem talking with Joel again.
我恰好住在加拿大，他们完成了这个过程。相信我，这很容易。用不了多久，你就会觉得34度很热了。只有缅甸……查菲四个月后就退出了。他在辩论中表现不佳，没有筹到多少钱，民调数字也很低。就像他没有完全掌握国家的脉搏一样。这是史蒂芬·米姆再次与乔尔交谈。
You know, his first order of business was to make the metric system, are we going to do measurement? It just became like really like that, that was just laughable, you know. He wasn't really reading every national tone, right? Was he? No, exactly, exactly. That was not part of Make America Great again. You know quote unquote. This episode was produced in collaboration with Joel Werner. He's the creator and host of a new
你知道，他的第一要务是让公制系统成为我们衡量的方式？这变得真的很像，那简直是可笑的，你知道。他并没有真正读懂每一个国家的基调，对吧？是吗？不，完全正确，完全正确。那不是“让美国再次伟大”的一部分。你知道，引用一下。本集是与乔尔·沃纳合作制作的。他是澳大利亚广播公司一个新节目的创作者和主持人，
podcast from the Australian Broadcasting Corporation called Some of All Parts. It tells stories about numbers, measurements, and data. Check it out and if you have a story that somehow involves a number, email the show at soapatabc.net.au. For my team Delaney Hall edited this piece and Sheree Fusif did the tech production and mix. Sean Real composed the music. Katie Mingle is our senior producer. Kurt Colstead is the digital director.
播客名为《万物之和》。它讲述关于数字、测量和数据的故事。去听听看，如果你有一个以某种方式涉及数字的故事，请发送电子邮件至soapatabc.net.au。对于我的团队，德莱尼·霍尔编辑了这篇稿件，谢丽·福西夫负责技术制作和混音。肖恩·里尔创作了音乐。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。
The rest of staff includes Avery Trollman and at the Cheryl, Terran Mazza and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the Night Foundation and Coin Carrying listeners, just like you.
其余工作人员包括艾弗里·特罗尔曼、安德烈·谢里尔、泰伦·马扎和我，罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心Radio Row制作。《99%隐形》是PRX RadioTopia的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的集合。我们得到了奈特基金会和像你一样的硬币携带听众的支持。
You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Ork. Run Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. If you want to read an article about the oldest national monuments in the U.S. or any of the other design stories that we release every single week, you have to go to our website, it's 99p i dot org. Radio tapio. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到《99%隐形》并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也有。如果你想阅读一篇关于美国最古老的国家纪念碑的文章，或者我们每周发布的任何其他设计故事，你必须去我们的网站，网址是99pi.org。RadioTopia。来自PRX。你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。